the whole
crowd was going crazy because no one had
ever seen people shoot like that
[Music]
[Applause]
when you talk about duncan robinson the
first thing comes to your mind is great
three-point shooter he's one of these
players that every coach when you talk
about playing the miami heat the one
thing they say is don't leave duncan
robinson why you can't leave him because
he'll knock down the three he can also
move without the basketball catch and
shoot every time you fall asleep and
they kick it to him boom he knocks down
the three well
there was another one that i'd like to
remind everybody of when we talk about
great shooters there's a gentleman that
grew up in chicago that i played against
in high school craig hodges one of the
best shooters to ever come out of
chicago one of the best shooters in the
pros
hodges from the corner with a football
try and it's through all alone for three
hodgin
[Applause]
so craig hodges when the three-point
line was becoming a weapon
history was was just different and what
made it so difficult to guard he had
michael jordan as his teammate so you
had to double team michael jordan who
was the you know the greatest mid-range
player ever but then when you double
team jordan you look out there and craig
hard just standing there with a nuclear
bomb saying oh you're going to leave me
here so do you want to give up the three
or do you want to give up the two to
jordan
that was your choice it was an
unbearable situation for dumars and i as
guards joe would say to me he think i
need a little help i got craig hodges
over here i can't leave him hey hey
sally can you help joe
hey robin can you help joe i mean
because we can't leave craig hodges
hasn't missed yet
look at this this is unbelievable
unbelievable
fans have been waiting for this that was
tremendous shooting in a three-point
shooting contest craig hodges holds the
record for macon listen to me when i say
this 19 threes in a row
pop pop
the whole
crowd was going crazy
because no one had ever seen people
shoot like that well people from chicago
who grew up in chicago watching craig
hodges do that was like oh man that's
just craig that's what he do you know we
was all happy to see craig i just do his
thing
here's hodges yes
it's robinson for three beautiful shot
three quarters for hodges
is demanding respect duncan
watching duncan robinson explode and
break out when he did in the bubble
watching him like shoot the basketball
and people chasing him all over the
court and every time he caught it
everybody was like oh man duncan got the
back that reminded me of how we used to
think when hodges was standing out at
the at the three-point line or when the
nba was looking at hodges and he was
just standing there by himself and
everybody was like oh no anybody but him
craig hodges he was one of the first to
come into the nba and totally change the
way defenses had to defend the offense
his jump shot was so potent and so
perfect that's what made craig college
special
[Music]
craig hodges look him up look at his
sweet form just i can still see it right
off his forehead and then
and sometimes he'd snap it back and look
at you drop his hands and while you're
walking back you like
craig hodges was a bad boy he was a bad
boy
you